and the kick down at the 35-yard line  and sarah fuller  happy thanksgiving what a day  what a day in college football  well sarah you made history today the  first female to  ever play in a power five football game  what emotions are you feeling now that  you've reached such a milestone  honestly it's just so exciting and the  fact that i can represent  like the little girls out there who've  wanted to do this or you know  thought about playing football or any  sport really and it encourages them to  be able to step out and do something big  like this so it's awesome  we were all patiently awaiting the  entire first half hoping we'd get to see  you take the field but you come out  after halftime  you take the field for the kickoff what  was your mentality in that moment  honestly i was just really calm the sec  championship was more stressful  but i was i was really excited to step  out on the field and do my thing so